[Music]
alright again tonight Sarah Carter has
unearthed one of the most revealing
pieces of information in the ongoing
saga between Bruce or and Christopher
Steele now for nearly two weeks we have
been showing you dozens of
communications between or whose one
please once the fourth highest ranking
person at Obama's DOJ and ex foreign spy
Christopher Steele now these new text
emails handwritten notes have provided
evidence of a seedy
unusual relationship between these two
including a coordinated effort to push
the contents of Steele's dirty
unverified Russian dossier all
throughout the DOJ and the FBI and just
tonight Sarah Carter has uncovered one
more handwritten memo from Bruce or
recording a phone conversation that he
had with Christopher Steele in the memo
or writes that Steele is quote very
concerned about the Comey hearing and
afraid they will be exposed now this is
on top of the text that Sarah first
revealed right here last night showing
that Steele was concerned about whether
or not plural firewalls will stay intact
ahead of commis upcoming hearing so you
have Christopher Steele worried about
being exposed and for good reason
after all it was Christopher Steele he
worked on Hillary Clinton's research
team in 2016 he put together the Clinton
bought and paid for dirty Russian
dossier full of Russian Lies salacious
unverified uncorroborated even steal
himself wouldn't stand by it under oath
in Great Britain he said well it may not
be true at all its raw intelligence it
was Christopher Steele who then used
Bruce or to spread all this Russian
propaganda throughout the highest levels
of our federal government and to you the
American people and now thanks to the
reporting also tonight from Catherine
Herridge we know it was Christopher
Steele who was leaking the contents of
his phony dossier to you're gullible
news media in this country in the fall
of 2016 all at the behest and requests
of fusion GPF who by the way was not
only being hated by paid by Hillary
Clinton and the DNC we now know fusion
GPS Oh remember that Russian lawyer the
one that was in the infamous Trump Tower
meeting
yeah she was paying fusion gps and by
the way don't forget Simpson
met with the lawyer both before and
after that meeting at Trump Tower and we
know Christopher Steel and Simpson were
clearly pushing their Russian lies they
all knew it was total BS by the way
that's why Steele wanted the firewall
that's why he's scared to death he will
get caught now a moment Sarah Carter and
Catherine Herridge will join us for a
full report but first let's take a deep
dive into president Trump's very
important security clearance review and
several current and former high ranking
officials yesterday the president's trip
top secret access from comrade John
Brennan and for good reason last night
as we demonstrated how Brennan clearly
violated the CIA policy it says quote in
the case of former CIA directors the
agency holds that their security
clearance and renews it every five years
for the rest of their lives however that
requires former CIA directors to behave
like current CIA employees well that's
not Brennan
now we also use the security clearance
to validate conspiracy theories that
he's regularly pushing and getting paid
for on MSNBC and leaking of course
sensitive information to the general
public as relates to the dossier through
Harry Reid then to a letter public
that's made to call me but the
mainstream media they don't care about
the truth or any of this some are now
actually claiming John Brennan's First
Amendment rights are infringed he's on
TV 24/7 what are they talking about take
a look this is a dictatorial exercise of
power that should frighten and call on
all Republicans to say mr. president you
cannot do this you are trying to inhibit
the free speech of people who may be in
opposition to you to use this kind of
punishment to chill speech is a
violation of the First Amendment I mean
this is a striking move towards
authoritarianism you know this is what
dictators do they shut down the press
and shut down dissent they jail their
opponents or in this case they steal
their security clearance what happened
here was a pure authoritarian Act
from an intemperate president who wanted
to punish one of his critics nothing
more nothing less right now but away
from John Lydon so doesn't that say to
everybody else shut your mouth this is
all dumb ignorant and frankly patently
absurd as John Brennan continues to spew
his anti-trump hatred all over
conspiracy TV MSNBC oh one other
important point a security clearance for
those of you that have never read the
Constitution and claim you're a
journalist it's not a constitutional
privilege it's a privilege and according
to the US Supreme Court Navy v Egan a
u.s. president has the authority to
revoke any clearance with or without
stated reason currently the
administration is reviewing the status
of nine clearances now with the help of
our good friend Fox News legal analyst
Greg Jarrett
let's break down why each of the people
you see on the screen should be in
serious jeopardy of losing their secret
access tonight we start with James
clapper without a doubt he should be
stripped of his security clearance as
soon as humanly possible he liked
Brennan also misuses his clearance to
validate and also monetize his hatred of
President Trump every time he's on TV
Brennan on conspiracy TV MSNBC clapper
doing the same thing on fake News CNN
take a look the the value standards the
institutions that that I and others
spent a major part of our professional
lives defending and upholding or under
assault by our very own president that I
really do wonder whether the Russians
have something on him I really question
his ability to his fitness to be in this
office and I also I'm beginning to
wonder about his motivation for it this
past weekend is illustrative of what a
great case officer Vladimir Putin is he
knows how to handle
an asset and that's what he's doing with
the president that's not the only reason
clapper should forfeit his clearance now
before his time at fake News CNN while
serving as the Director of National
Intelligence
well clapper was accused of leaking
sensitive information to his future
employers CNN the company that employs
them now and let's not forget when
clapper lied under oath in front of
Congress
take a look does the NSA collect any
type of data at all on millions or
hundreds of millions of Americans no sir
it does not not wittingly there are
cases where they could inadvertently
perhaps collect but not not wittingly
now of course we know that the exact
opposite is true the NSA was collecting
the data he knew about it next let's
turn to Jimmy Comey yeah he's his access
has already gone but he's still eligible
for future access and as Gregg Jarrett
lists multiple reasons Comey should be
permanently losing his eligibility
including his improper conduct and
clinton investigation the fact that he
stole government property
remember the handwritten memos about the
president remember he leaked that
potentially classified information those
memos to a professor friend to give to
the New York Times and he also likely
misled the FISA Court about the steal
dossier that he was supposed to verify
it never did and then he lied about that
during his book tour will remind you you
called the dossier unverified salacious
why did you use that to define a court
to ask for surveillance for Carter page
not only use it but you led with it a
bulk of that FISA application deals with
that dossier why yeah that's not my
recollection Brett and I don't know that
the FISA application has been released
my recollection was it was part of a
broader mosaic of facts that were laid
before the FISA judge to obtain a FISA
warrant it was a lot more than the
dossier in the FISA application my
recollection was there was a significant
amount of additional material about page
and why there was probable cause to
believe he was an agent of a foreign
power and the dossier was part of that
but was not all of it or could
it's my recollection unreal we now know
that da say did in fact make up the bulk
of the application it's an irrefutable
fact at this point next up well let's
look at Peter struck he was also fired
for improper conduct his extreme bias is
willingness to act on that bias is a
reason alone he should never have a
clearance again we also have his
mistress Lisa Paige
the one-time FBI lawyer also complicit
as it relates to structs bias and his
attempts to quote stop it meaning stop
Trump from ever becoming president then
of course the insurance policy and then
there's Andrew McCabe he was fired for
lying he was also involved in signing
off on that fake FISA application that
willfully misled FISA Court judges by
the way and the American people and we
got Sally Yates also fired for
insubordination
she signed off on one of the FISA
applications Susan Rice she lied all
over the place over and over about
Benghazi when they knew better a matter
of national security
really knowingly lying get rid of her
clearance next he got Michael Hayden
Greg Jared is calling his security
clearance case quote questionable but
remember Hayden is currently employed by
CNN as a talking head and finally we end
on Bruce or he was once the fourth
highest ranking member the DOJ before
being demoted twice why for failing to
disclose his wife's employment at fusion
GPS we can add Christopher steel to the
mix now in fact or was actively working
on an investigation into Trump Russia
collusion while his wife was being paid
by the Clinton campaign to dig up dirt
on Trump or appears also to have filed a
false financial disclosure report in
order to prevent the government from
knowing the true nature of his wife's
work in moments Greg Gerald will join us
with more analysis but without a doubt
the Trump administration was right in
the case of Brennan and now should
revoke all of these clearances as soon
as possible right now we turn to our
daily roundup of the most arranged Trump
haters and tonight we're featuring this
absurd comment yeah once again
conspiracy TV MSNBC take a look I like
the idea that let that you know you see
is the examples the bad example of
like what would be the core that would
say it was okay for Donald Trump to
dissolve media institutions because he
is just a super unpopular I would like a
pollster test this question how many
people in the Republican Party think
that it would be okay for Donald Trump
to dissolve their own grandparents I'm
virtually certain that if it was a
Donald Trump related question you get
like 10% that would be like Donald Trump
has the power to everyone sin cluding
killed my parents and today President
Trump gave his own take on the media's
Trump derangement syndrome tweeting
quote there is nothing that I would want
more for our country than true freedom
of the press the fact is that the press
is free to write and say anything they
want but much of what it says is fake
news pushing a political agenda or just
plain trying to hurt people
honesty wins maybe that's why you've
made us number one and we thank you for
it expect the media's rhetoric by the
way to get worse and worse as the most
important midterms of our lifetime
well gets closer we're only 82 days away
this week congressman keith Ellison he
won the Democratic primary in his race
to be the next Attorney General of
Minnesota but not without some serious
controversy Alison's ex-girlfriend a
woman named Karen Monahan is accusing
him of serious domestic abuse a claim
backed up by Monaghan's son who took to
Facebook and wrote that Ellison put his
mother through quote pure health and
that he had personally seen hundreds of
threatening text messages from Ellison
and even a video of Ellison about two
minutes long assaulting his mother
including one instance where he
allegedly dragged her by her feet off
the bed all while screaming and cursing
at her now these are charges that
ellison vehemently denies but the DNC is
now investigating these claims and Robby
Mook of the Clinton campaign saying
don't campaign with this guy I'll keep
you posted as this story develops and
finally tonight we have another update
in the trial of the century Paul man
affords 2005 tax case and bank fraud
case well the jury they wrapped up day 1
of deliberations without reaching a
verdict the jury did however submit four
questions to judge Ellis including one
asking him to define or redefine
reasonable doubt as maybe a good sign
for metaphor but I caution you remember
you can't glean too much from a question
of a jury and over 90%
federal cases result in a guilty verdict
the odds are not in manna forts favor
keep in mind as the media storm ramps up
on this this case has nothing zero mr.
Muller to do with Russia zero mr. Muller
to do with any collusion zero mr. Muller
to do with the 2016 campaign and zero to
do mr. Muller with Donald Trump and this
all comes as the wife of one of Muller's
targets George papadopolis who was just
on with Tucker is calling for her
husband to scrap that plea deal that he
made with Muller and sue the government
will let you know Papadopoulos takes his
wife's advice and by the way takes on
the aggressive tactics of team Muller a
lot of ground a lot of news were
breaking